I'm sure you get asked plenty what is
consciousness and emptiness okay well
according to the Buddhists uh emptiness
is a word that is used to describe what
you really are at the deepest level
so what you are is not a thing it's a
process so one way to look at Emptiness
is that it's a process of colorizing or
codependent origination for example me
and you are speaking right now and uh
we're both arising and co-creating each
other just like how particles where they
observe each other they kind of you know
give rise to each other and before this
process of interaction you are in this
state of interdeterminacy like a pure
potentiality kind of thing it's like
like you know we put the cat in the box
if you don't open it it's neither dead
or alive and both kind of thing so
emptiness could be defined as a process
of co-creation and before this process
is realize
um what you really are is in a state of
indeterminacy or pure potentiality
so the me Chronicle me
is only arising the way it is at this
moment because of the way you are rising
so neither of us has inherent existence
apart from this relation or in
interconnectedness so in and of
ourselves we are empty that's one way to
perceive emptiness another way to
perceive emptiness is more of a more of
a direct experience kind of thing for
example
um because of the meditation I've been
doing
um we can talk about the techniques
later but I've been meditating for 10
years and
on May 25 to 2020 I went through a shift
uh what I described as reaching the uh
wisdom exit so the emptiness axis of
this spiritual or contemplative
development to the end point and I
everything you need from that moment on
uh it was it was a permanent shift in my
Consciousness in my based on
Consciousness from that point out where
everything that I perceive is Quantico
empty what that means is that my direct
perception right now is boundless it
doesn't have any uh separations uh this
vast and the awareness is panoramic
and uh everything becomes like
holographic everything I perceive is
like a hologram kind of like how you put
on a virtual reality goggle you know
that the image that you perceive is not
ultimately real it doesn't have any hair
in existence you're just perceiving you
know a holographic image dancing pixels
and lights
and when you take off the VR goggle you
think that you are already in the real
world now and everything is solid but in
actuality of direct experience at least
when you realize your true nature when
you take out the VR goggle you're
actually still perceiving a virtual
reality uh the virtuality of the mind
you can call it that and when I look at
the computer screen right now there's no
distance between me and the screen so
the air between objects or the gaps
between objects is a spool as the object
themselves so you can say that all the
objects all the clinical material
objects that are perceived in the
clinical external world are Holograms or
you can say that the distance or the the
space between those objects are full so
that's another way to perceive emptiness
in a more kind of a perceptual way as
rather direct experience is that
everything is full and empty
simultaneously because if something is
completely empty it's also completely
full so that's why a lot of spiritual
Traditions focuses on love and
compassion because emptiness and love
are two sides of the same coin if you
are a conical complete empty you also
are completely full and you're able to
express love
so that's another way to look at
emptiness and I think the most important
thing to know about emptiness is that
emptiness and form are identical you
know empty this is formed inform is
emptiness or another way to look at it
is I'm sorry is no other than Nevada
that's another way to perceive emptiness
um another way to perceive emptiness and
this is probably the last one that I go
into is what idea Shantae calls the the
dark light of the absolute so that's how
he describes the true nature it's like
emptiness is kind of like the merging of
a singularity which has no size no
dimensions and no locations
with Palace and infinite Consciousness
so you know how a lot of spiritual mumbo
jumbo say you're everything you're
nothing and that's what they're talking
about so in my direct experience it's
really hard to describe but if I can
describe it using that you know under
that context of the apps the the dark
light of the absolute it feels like
something that's extremely dark but also
extremely bright something that is
everything but it's on nothing so it
feels like you're a singularity that
small Chronicles smaller than the size
of an atom which you know that's just a
metaphor because it doesn't have a
location it's not even a point but as a
matter of